seven years ago I couldn't stand
Assassin's Creed 3 its recent remaster
changed my mind upon its initial 2012
release Assassin's Creed 3 was divisive
to say the least
critically it was well received the
Metacritic score sits at 84 with
numerous publications calling it the
best Series entry to date they praised
its characters setting and wealth of
open-world activities if metacritic were
the sole indication of a games worth
Assassin's Creed 3 would have a
sparkling reputation but the other group
one to which I belong since 2012
told a much more tarnished story of a
game with technical issues and sloppy
mechanics a boring protagonist and
menial open-world quests it was a messy
conglomeration of action set-pieces that
never really meshed and as the series
continued its steady march I
consistently ranked it at the bottom of
my personal list but lo and behold the
credits have just rolled on my first
replay in seven years and I'm eating my
words here is a remaster that doesn't
confirm my vision of the past but up
ends it completely many of my original
frustrations remain yes but the
franchise is different today than it
once was
it's bigger more complicated and my
relation to it has evolved as is often
the result of time context and
resounding personal improvement my view
of Assassin's Creed 3 has changed now I
can see it for what it is a key turning
point in one of the most pervasive
franchises today first off let's talk
about that intro that six hour prologue
that puts you in the shoes of the
unadvertised Haytham Kenway that opening
chunk that illustrates just how similar
the Templars really are to their
assassin rivals these few chapters
humanize the villainous father figure in
a way the Star Wars prequels only dreamt
of doing as you could probably tell I
adore this introduction but in 2012 I
did not in fact I resented it I resented
it for keeping me from playing Connor
this badass Mohawk assassin with his
tomahawk skills and cover art stoicism I
wanted hate thumbs chapter to end almost
as soon as it began despite the twist
that I had been playing as a Templar all
long but I now see how essential that
intro is it reverberates throughout the
entire game as I finally step into
Connors shoes join the assassin
Brotherhood and become embroiled in the
American Revolution I have a clear
target every step of the way
my Templar enemies aren't just names and
faces they're a guy I saved from the
Redcoats or when I rescued from torture
only to help him exact revenge I even
met one in a Boston pub drunkenly
welcoming me to the new world I may have
done these things as Connors father but
that's the point Connor isn't the only
conduit for player agency in the game
and it helps drive the story home the
templars aren't just friends of haytham
Zoar enemies of Connor's they're my
friends and they're my enemies and this
brings me to Connor himself and if I'm
honest my opinion here has not changed
at times he's endearing at times he's
unbearably boring I love the idea that
he's stuck between worlds unsure of
where he belongs pulled between his
Mohawk tribe the assassin Brotherhood
and both sides of the revolution but the
pacing can be so slipshod and Connors
delivery so bland that much of it falls
flat
I get that his confusion and uncertainty
are meant to further drive home the
moral graves of the assassin Templar
conflict but that doesn't excuse Connors
overall lack of spark I can only point
out two times when I was impressed by
his delivery and in both cases he was
consumed with anger
there's no range in his emotions he's
either at an 11 or a 1 this is also
reflected in ac3 stilted character
movement despite the remasters upgraded
textures Ubisoft Barcelona was working
with dated animations and it shows
phases don't convey the right emotion or
in some cases any emotion at all and
Connors feet can't help but magnetize
toward nearby objects at the slightest
touch at his best Connor is more a man
of action than words but when his
actions don't line up with my intent the
cracks really start to show a c3 7-year
old skeleton notwithstanding Connor
remains one of the more tragic figures
in a franchise rife with them throughout
most of the story he's told that he's a
messenger and little more not to dive
too deep into the zany modern-day
storyline of the franchise but basically
you play as Connor so the modern-day
Desmond
reliving his ancestral memories can find
the key to stopping the end of the world
much of Assassin's Creed 3 revolves
around the potential for one person to
make a difference when forces on every
side are set against him this conflict
leads him to kill not just his father
but also his best friend Connor may
falter in his delivery but Ubisoft scrip
places him in a conflicted dramatic spot
if you anticipated Assassin's Creed 3 as
eagerly as I did in 2012 you may have
also worried about the musical direction
of the numerous changes to staff and
direction following the Ezio trilogy one
of the more notable departures was that
of Jesper Kyd the composer responsible
for the musical identity of the first
four games he helped shape each
atmosphere with his period piece
ensembles to lose him was a major blow
to the franchise but upon returning I
can't help but appreciate the confident
quiet ac3 has there are occasional
orchestral touches as you explore the
landscape but they're subtle restrained
the wind is muffled in the underground
tunnels and the frontiers pulled
straight from a Robert Frost poem
I can't say whether the sparse
soundtrack is a result of kids departure
or a decision to just let the wilderness
breathe on its own I just know there's a
peaceful quality to AC threes more
pastoral environments which reminds me
that despite criticisms following early
trailers that Assassin's Creed 3 would
be pro-american the game doesn't
actually romanticize anything about the
revolution let alone pick a side it does
however romanticize of the frontier this
virgin land Connors tribe has sworn to
protect Assassin's Creed 3 used the
frontier to completely revamp the flow
of the franchise's parkour altai ear and
Ezio spent most of their time in urban
environments clambering along rooftops
and over dense crowds in ac3 though
Connor darts through the forest canopy
stalking his prey among natural
formations oddly enough I'm reminded of
the way Metal Gear Solid 3 snake year
brought the series stealth formula to a
more open environment it stressed
cooperation with the wilderness and
reliance on organic materials Conners
adventure is less focused on survival
than naked snakes was but it was a
drastic change regardless and it opened
up new avenues for future Assassin's
Creed settings last year in my video
about the franchise's evolution I used a
quote from Jade Raymond creator of the
Assassin's Creed series founder of EA
motive and recently head of Google's new
stadiums and entertainment to name a few
of her many many accolades in an
interview with The Guardian though she
described the series in a way that sums
it up really well and I still haven't
found a better quote since she called
assassin's Creed a sandbox for creatives
basically it's this thing that creators
can mold into their own vision and after
my recent playthrough unconvinced
Assassin's Creed 3 is one of the key
turning points in the ever-evolving
series it brought in the scope and
brought the formula to new environments
it introduced the beloved naval combat
and paved the way for Assassin's Creed
rogues Templar protagonists for better
or worse it took the kitchen sink
approach with its open-world activities
making Brotherhood already bursting at
the seams with things to do look sparse
by comparison to use Raymond's words it
was a sandbox for creatives and it helps
another decade of sandboxes to come so
it's all the more astonishing to recall
that before its global success
Assassin's Creed was originally planned
as a trilogy ac3 closed out Desmond's
story and it was supposed to bring
finality to the end of the world arc and
for all intents and purposes remain the
last numbered entry in the Assassin's
Creed franchise as Raymond said in the
same interview even she didn't plan on
more than three titles but despite any
initial intent for a singular trilogy
Ubisoft faced the difficult task of
extending a narrative that was
originally supposed to bring closure
much like its protagonists torn between
the worlds of the Mohawk the assassins
and the warring colonists Assassin's
Creed 3 had to become a conduit for
something bigger like Connor ac3 had to
find its place between conflicting ideas
but it also had to establish an identity
of its own it has an age well in many
respects but it's remaster has ignited
my appreciation for what I previously
deemed a mediocre title and as far as
remasters go I'd call that a success